[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight here's where we are tens of
thousands of americans continue to die
in their prime from drug Odie's the
middle class is still shrinking housing
prices in our cities are crushing an
entire generation of ambitious young
people China's economy is about to
overtake ours so that's all the bad news
right there but have no fear here's the
good news Washington is on it your
representatives in the capitol city this
city just spent their third day in a row
yelling at each other but a phone call
Donald Trump once made to some guy in
Ukraine in other words the impeachment
trial of the president rules on tonight
and if nothing else that means that
amateur thespian and full time
congressman Adam Schiff gets to try out
new parts for the camera yesterday
you'll remember shift played the role of
wartime general rallying the country in
the face of an imminent military
invasion the Russians are coming he
squeaked the Russians are coming watch
there's one witness put it during our
impeachment inquiry the United States
aid Ukraine and her people so that we
can fight Russia over there and we don't
have to fight Russia here that's right
ladies and gentlemen we could soon fight
the Russians here in st. Johnsbury not
st. Petersburg stock up on milk well
today in a reprise of that performance
Schiff revived the character you saw but
with a theological dimension wartime
general plus Old Testament prophet
George Patton meets Jeremiah suddenly
Adams shift that hero to secular America
was dropping references to God like the
two were old friends
thank God Putin said thank God nobody is
accusing us anymore of interfering in
u.s. elections now they're accusing
Ukraine thank God Putin says I don't
think we really want radomir Putin our
adversary to be thanking God for the
President of the United States because
they don't wish us well we do not want
them thanking God for our president and
what he is pushing out we don't want
them
making God for withholding money from
our ally now say what you will but as a
piece of theater it had literally
everything there was dastardly old
Vladimir Putin rubbing his hands
together and diabolical bleah somewhere
deep beneath the Kremlin those foolish
Americans little do they know my troops
will be in Phoenix by nightfall
on the other side God Himself in heaven
looking down in sadness hoping this lost
nation will finally heed Saint Adams
prophetic warnings and obey it was the
age-old battle of good versus evil
playing out right there on the Senate
floor on c-span Senator Jim Risch of
Idaho though was not impressed
he felt dead asleep the other day and he
probably wasn't the only one to do it if
it weren't for the fact that most
senators can nap with their eyes open it
would be clear that the whole chamber
has been unconscious since Monday and
can you blame them for that
it's interminable and yet on cable news
it's like Christmas America's news rooms
may be the last place in the
english-speaking world where Adam Schiff
is still considered impressive to her
average news anchor Adam Schiff is not a
bug-eyed hysteric
he's a statesman Alexander Hamilton
reborn get that man a musical a very
very powerful and forceful speech to an
almost two and a half hours by Adam
Schiff for the very very strong case I
thought ships performance was a virtuoso
performance yesterday Adam Schiff did
masterfully what all prosecutors are
trained to do he is a really good lawyer
period end of discussion and also I
thought shifted an exceptionally good
job connecting his case to the founding
fathers I have to say watching that I
thought Adams shifts opening was
brilliant this visit speech really aimed
at the better angels by most accounts it
was a virtuoso performance that drew
praise from all sides yesterday it was a
stunning recitation of the facts what
did you think of the presentation by the
lead house manager Adam Schiff I thought
it was dazzling dazzling stunning
brilliant powerful forceful masterful
virtuoso whatever that means those are
the words the press uses to describe a
man who's just called for a hot war
against a nuclear-armed nation to the
Talking Heads on CNN believe what Schiff
is saying do they actually think
Russia's on the cusp of invading the
United States maybe they do more likely
they're not really listening to him if
the internal thoughts of your average
news anchor were broadcast on the screen
and they should be you'd see they were
evolved mostly around hair and makeup do
my ears look big these are not policy
people they don't care about details
they just know for certain that Schiff
is on their team and that's enough for
them
that's something it's been the last few
years studiously pretending that Adam
Schiff is a serious person and not a
wild-eyed conspiracy nut now to keep
pretending that they've had to ignore a
lot of his actual claims the things he's
saying very much including these things
you can see evidence in plain sight on
the issue of collusion pretty compelling
evidence and there is significant
evidence of collusion there is ample
evidence and indeed there is of
collusion of people in the Trump
campaign with the Russians I think
there's plenty of evidence of collusion
or conspiracy all of this is evidence of
collusion Schiff collusion was
everywhere on Facebook on television
inside the box of honey bunches of oats
sitting in the breakfast nook in his
airless Capitol Hill apartment at one
point he even began to suspect his cats
his many cats Schiff spent the entirety
of 2017 and 2018 talking just like that
by the end he'd accuse 60 million
Americans of colluding with Vladimir
Putin simply by the act of voting for
Donald Trump was a conspiracy that
profound he said it wasn't and that's
the remarkable part Schiff was wrong
none of this ever happened and we now
know that conclusively so shift punished
for this driven from polite society for
falsely impugning the integrity of
millions Americans with lies which he
did no he wasn't he just got more famous
and more revered on MSNBC you can find
in most weekdays now having lunch in the
best restaurants in the city right
across from the guys who planned the
Iraq war and got rich from securitizing
subprime mortgages Schiff seems happy
and why wouldn't he be he got it all
completely wrong but he wasn't Thomas
just the opposite he was rewarded that's
how Washington really works keep that in
mind as you watch Adams shifts
run around the Senate this week playing
whatever character he's chosen that day
this is the guy making the big decisions
this is the guy they admire